it's time for a new segment that we're
calling drew in your business
um where i help entrepreneurs take their
businesses to the next
level and i am so excited to kick off
this segment with a woman
who is just as sweet as her business
take a look
my name is stephanie davison and i'm the
owner of oh for the love of cheesecakes
i make these yummy and scrumptious
cheesecakes
and i did the unthinkable in the middle
of a pandemic when unemployment rates
are super high
i quit my good job to stay at home and
make these cheesecakes
now becoming an entrepreneur is very
scary and i'm not gonna lie it's hard
i consider drew to be the ultimate
business person and i have my pen
and my paper and i'm ready to take notes
drew will you help me well
thank you stephanie and yes i would love
to i'd love to get up in your business
stephanie where are you
i'm right here hi drew hi stephanie
thank you so much for coming on the show
and telling us about your
amazing business i just want to ask a
question that
i would think if i was watching this
would be my first burning question which
is
how did you do this in the middle of a
pandemic quit a job
and how is it going it is it's going
really good
um you know i was at work and i was
sitting behind a computer and i'm just
like looking out at the sun and
you know i just wanted more and i
started making cheesecakes for people at
work
for their birthdays and they started
saying you should make these
you should sell these and i'm like no i
can't do that and they said yes you
should
well that idea just kind of grew and
grew and grew
and what i learned in 2020 is that
you just got to jump in and take that
risk do
you think that you are happier now
oh most definitely most definitely
i don't understand how happy that makes
me because i know
i know there are people who are afraid
to take the leap
and there is that thing about the
importance of happiness and it is not
some
bs lofty you know
mug it's not it's like a hard-earned you
have to fight for it you have to
reconfigure your life you have to keep
working on yourself
you have to take risks it's hard to be
happy
it is you know when you you
are the one that's putting in all the
work you have to do
this and you get so much back
like to me it's the
the biggest high that i can get is when
somebody looks at my cheesecakes and
says
oh my gosh that is so pretty or that's
so beautiful
it tastes so amazing that makes it all
worth it for me
okay so how has business been
um it's actually grown quite fast
um it's a little overwhelming at times
um last thanksgiving uh in 2019
i had seven cheesecakes and i thought oh
my gosh
how am i gonna do seven cheesecakes well
this past
thanksgiving it was anywhere between 110
to 120 cheesecakes oh my gosh gosh
grown a lot um do i have this right that
you have five
ovens and three refrigerators i do
i do i love picturing that as soon as i
read that
i could just see you like just you know
with the spinning plates and
multitasking and
doing it all and you know is that what
the current work process looks like
spinning plates and running to ovens and
fridges and managing 130
orders for one thanksgiving
yeah that was that was quite the task
um i have to give props to excel
because my spreadsheet was what kept me
going
um but yes you know you you're
constantly switching out your
cheesecakes
oh this one's done then you put another
one in oh
now i gotta run over to this oven this
one's done so i got to take that out put
another one
in this one needs cooled so i need to
move it to the counter
well now it's in the second phase of
cooling so now i got to move it to the
refrigerator
so yeah it is a lot of plates does it it
sounds like that does it look like this
mirror yes it does
not as grateful though as you
oh i highly doubt that okay what are
your goals
now my goal is that i've actually
outgrown my kitchen space here
um i want to get that storefront i want
to be
able to have that cheesecake
somebody comes in for a piece of
cheesecake over a cup of coffee with
their bff
on a weekday afternoon i want a place
for people to hang out
study but be able to come to the counter
when they need one and one's right there
or continue to have that customized
cheesecake but also not lose that
one-on-one
uh feeling that what i first started
with
okay so it's like julia childs meet
central perk
okay i get it
you